bonjour philippe petit monde où moïse le
bon vous êtes le président de l'udps et
martinique merci d'être avec nous dans
ça au cas dit il ne vous a pas échappé
si petit que le calendrier politique
national français marquée aujourd'hui
par la clôture des candidatures pour la
primaire de la droite et du centre en
vue de la présidentielle de l'année
prochaine 13 candidats annoncés on a
quand même plus parler de la droite que
du centre c'est exact et j'ai d'ailleurs
il ya même je dirais quelque chose
d'assez paradoxal c'est qu'on parle de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
alors qu'il n'y a pas deux centristes à
l'intérieur de cette prime et loués ya
déjà un problème
et puis je pense que l'effective manche
c'était là prix mérité fait ou fait
beaucoup de médiatisation et e pour un
faux suspense puisque on sait très bien
que si les majors qui vont s'expliquer
le centre ça demeure une notion plutôt
floues une notion qui n'a jamais
vraiment pu trouver sa place à lorient
il le dernier président centriste
effectivement il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui n'étaient pas nés c'était valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a été lu en 1974
c'est à dire ça fait 42 ans si je compte
bien mais le centre a toujours existé
parce que c'est le centre qui
traditionnellement est une force
pourront tourner pourra-t-on dire
d'appoint qui permet qu'une majorité
d'indécis de gens qui sont je dirais
modéré l'ajustement sergio bélier
variable saha de géométrie variable je
vais vous expliquer que à une époque que
c'est mitterrand d'ailleurs qu'avec bien
qualifié le centre en disant qu'il
n'était ni de gauche ni de gauche
sous-entendu que le centre a toujours
voté avec la droite parce qu'il y avait
quand même 2 avant tout une notion
économique que la gauche en tout cas de
l'époque qui n'était pas une gauche
libérale on parlera tout à l'heure je
suppose des manuels macron mettait en
avant c'est à dire qu'on distribuait
avant même d'avoir créé des richesses
c'était ça la valeur de la gauche et par
conséquent ça ne veut pas manger sinon a
endetté la france telle qu'elle est
endetté aujourd'hui donc le centre a
toute sa place parce qu'il a des valeurs
humanistes et qu'il veut justement
tempérer la droite dure la loi de fortes
la droite un petit peu des fois
exécrables et c'était là justement le
but que le centre existe notamment dans
cette primaire mais ça n'a pas pu
s'offrir la définition du centre-ville
concevez et que vous venez exposer ici
et puis à ce centre ici en martinique
élan corp fait recours plus à géométrie
variable on va dire alors le centre à la
martinique vous savez qu'il n'a jamais
existé par contre c'est une notion en
france qui a existé mais à la martinique
le fait que ces airs et le ppm en
particulier est pris sous la
personnalité forte de saisir toute une
partie d'une bourgeoisie toute une
partie d'un certain nombre de
travailleurs martiniquais le fait que la
droite était très tôt accroc accrochés
aux forces économiques pour représenter
à l'époque les usiniers les békés ont
fait qu'il ya eu
comment dirais-je schisme qui ont fait
que c'était vraiment quelque chose on ne
pouvait pas retrouvé les centristes des
gens qui pouvaient intellectuellement
existé et qui pouvait surtout permettre
10000 apte à séduire
donc c'est très dur et je vous avoue que
c'est une gageure et que quand vous êtes
président de lui dit vous savez que vous
avez du travail le vent alors la
situation martiniquaise pour lui dit
qu'ils te mouvement national rappelle
l'édile a pris une véritable soufflante
lors des élections de décembre dernier
philippe petit traumatisme passé
convalescence finie place à la
reconquête
alors il a bon je vous expliquer une
chose de violent très simplement il n'y
a jamais de soufflante ou de
traumatismes en politique c'est à dire
que vous quand même nom où vous faites
de la politique où vous n'en faites pas
si vous faites de la politique vous
savez que vers bien au mal vous pouvez
vous pouvez parler très bien je parle
très bien devant votre micro ouvert et
mettre les idées judicieuse j'en ai mais
souvent des judicieux élus de martinique
en particulier et que comme vous n'allez
pas de relais dans la population parce
que vous n'avez pas de mairie parce que
vous n'avez pas de conseillers généraux
parce que vous n'avez pas de corps
intermédiaires bien vous passez à côté
mais ça ne veut pas dire que vous n'avez
pas assez sur la situation de stratégie
ça veut pas dire que vous n'avez pas été
écouté ça vous n'avez pas ne pas dire
qu'on ne passe pas du bien de vous par
contre effectivement au niveau des
résultats
quand vous n'êtes pas élu que vous soyez
perdant à 49,99 bon sens où que vous
soyez perdra un bon sens si vous avez
été entendu laissé l'essentiel est que
on espère toujours que dans le programme
des autres sera repris les bonnes choses
que vous avez dit que vous n'avez jamais
eu envie de pratiquer la politique des
petits pas des petits bonds au lieu de
de se lancer à la conquête des
législatives puisqu'il sera il sera ce
sera le cas avec votre formation vous
pourriez peut-être essayer de rentrer
davantage dans les mairies mais tous les
efforts bien c'est ce que lui dit
monsieur je suis vieux le temps du déni
de 2014 à la martinique c'est à dire
qu'à la date d'aujourd'hui ça fait juste
12 ans nous existons
ça fait 15 ans le 20 août vous êtes
vieux routier un départ décalé qui
m'avait parlé de lui dit c'est la
chanson dont on avait parlé de lui dit
et je vous explique que lui dit va
tenter effectivement dans les années
2020 je ne sais pas si je serais
personnellement toujours à la tête de
l'ue dit mais d'avoir des conseillers
municipaux peut être des têtes de listes
dans les mairies 2020 si dans quatre ans
si loin et si tu mangeras de la codi
deuxième petit décontenancé monsieur le
plombe pas du tout je pense que votre
émission et fait effectivement pour
pouvoir sonder l'âme des gens et j'aime
je pense que les auditeurs percevant
quelqu'un de totalement en phase avec
lui même je fais de la politique parce
que j'aime ça je crois aux valeurs
libérales je lis toujours dit je viens
le mouvement que j'ai monté moi même le
mouvement libéral martiniquais c'est à
dire les valeurs d'une gauche libérale
ce que reprend vingt ans après macron et
je suis très content je ne sais pas si
ça fera une bulle médiatique
j'espère d'ailleurs qu'il s'alliera et
qu'il y aura probablement un bloc
centriste mais il faut attendre le
résultat des primes et en pour savoir à
la suite des primaires si effectivement
le vainqueur des primaires plus
s'entendre avec les centristes
alors on parlera de décembre de l'an
dernier avec ce très petit score que
vous avez réalisé mais vous annoncer
quand même des noms pour les
législatives il ya le nom de marie
victoire venus ce peloton dans deux
centres atlantique il ya le vôtre dans
le sud
ça se présente comment cette élection
législative
vous avez parlé de salaire de deux
moyens j'imagine que votre volonté
politique est très très forte puisque
vous représentez mais pour le reste
alors pour ceux qui considèrent alors
qu'ils ont ce qui concerne ce qui
concerne les élections vous avez un
système national qui pressent qui
investit des gens après ces gens dont
ils nous ont demandé la parité il se
trouve qu'il ya eu deux personnes qui
étaient volontaires potentiellement ou
en tout cas dont les militants
pressentait qu'ils avaient les capacités
à mener une campagne législative et à
partir de là paris nous investit
maintenant est ce que nous nous irons
localement je vous avoue alors j'ai pas
employé le thème que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure je crois désabusé je vous
avoue que si c'est pour être inaudible
et si ces bouffées sco relativement bas
est ce que ça vaut le coup nous nous
pencherons sur la situation une fois
parce qu'il ya eu deux heures saj parce
que non
c'est pourquoi parce que philippe petit
a toujours été sa vache mais c'est
toujours aux militants y restera un
militant peut être un militant hors de
la scène politique et faire tout
simplement comme beaucoup de formations
politiques qui disent des choses
indépendante histoire de kiel
suffisament les pressions que vous étiez
ne se présente pas que le frère et
goûter on peut toujours je redis ce que
je dis depuis toujours être à
l'extérieur et être sage effectivement
on peut toujours aussi être un sage en
étant un militant engagé parce que
lorsque vous êtes sur un plateau
télévisé ou l'osmose est une radio vous
n'êtes pas forcément des bêtises donc je
pense que je ne dis pas ça m'arrive d'en
dire comme comme tout homme politique un
camp dit mais je pense que j'entendais
votre visage
je pense que j'en dis peu au regard de
mes apparitions et donc je pense qu'on
aura effectivement probablement notre
carte à jouer pourquoi parce que tout
simplement je pense que du bloc ne
peuvent pas représenter un blog
autonomistes un bloc indépendantiste ça
me paraît irréel pour représenter la
nation française alors que tous ont beau
la nation martiniquaise
comment faire pour exister pour se faire
entendre avec ces deux blocs qui sont
particulièrement bien et staline
si sur des thèmes majeurs comme le
transport d'énergie de lycée schoelcher
des thèmes qui qui font désordre qui
divise et qui font qu'ils alimentent
sûrs certains bois vous pensez pouvoir
sortir notre épingle du jeu alors quand
vous êtes à la tête de la collectivité
ou quand vous avez des mairies bond
inattendu ils font beaucoup plus de
bruit effectivement le battage
médiatique et en leur faveur de tout le
temps puisqu'on entend tous les jours
parler d'eux vous allez faire de bruit
agace de plus en plus la lola sur martin
maintenant est ce que la population va
en fait réagir en disant mais c'est pas
vrai on ne peut pas avoir les élus que
nous avons un savoir qu'ils ne sont pas
capables de se mettre autour d'une table
pour le tcsp je vois des articles tous
les jours sur le net je vois des 2 alors
que normalement
l'europe nous donne le lange l'europe
nous dit de faire
nous sommes incapables tous les
intellectuels de ces partis politiques
de faire alors j'espère qu'ils
regarderont d'autres personnes en
l'occurrence si je me présente mais je
vous avoue que je ne sais pas à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui alors vous parliez aussi
de finances est effectivement comme tout
le monde quand vous faites de la
politique les gens ne le savent pas mais
ça coûte de l'argent et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les législatives sont
intéressantes parce qu'elles permettent
de donner aux partis politiques des sous
à la fonction du nombre de voix et donc
j'attendrais patiemment je pense le mois
de novembre la fin de l'année pour
pouvoir avec mes collègues de l'ue
démenti avec le national décider
de notre participation ou non aux
législatives de juin 2010 cet été dans
le sud de vous partez à l'assaut d'une
forteresse qui semble étonnant
imprenable est au châble en ce moment
avec sur ce rythme là il n'y a jamais eu
d'élections perdues ou de bataille
perdue tant qu'on ne les a pas livry ça
c'est une vérité donc vous savez jaffe
livni laurie certainement
beau garçon gentil garçon et qui
travaillent ces termes à l'assemblée
nationale on verra le moment venu si les
électeurs lui reconduit 6 estime qu'il a
fait son travail de député s'ils à voter
des lois pour la vente unique - tout cas
je n'en ai pas entendu spécialement
déchets pas entendu de loi nylon je ne
sais pas si effectivement à travers leur
alliance avec la droite est ce que nous
avons voulu une droite indépendantiste
ou est ce que c'est ce sont des
indépendantistes on retrouve ce sont des
indépendantistes de droit quand ils se
sont dévoilés aujourd'hui vous savez que
je suis curieux de savoir ce que cette
alliance de la carpe et du lapin va
donner donc j'attends patiemment et je
saurai le moment venu s'il faut se
présenter en tout cas avant des
arguments sur un plateau télévisé et sur
une radio si vous me réinviter merci
d'avoir été avec nos philippe petit on
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'udps et y martinique et que vous avez
effectué votre rentrée en fin de semaine
dernière merci d'avant était avec nous
dans sans aucun doute